the question is what is the
straight-line depreciation every year
okay what do you think is the most
accurate way to work it out because we
saw if we tried to do it off like one
year we were off by quite a margin right
you can see I was getting inaccurate
results so what might be a way to get a
more reasonable response yeah fantastic
okay so we said we started at 15,000
right now actually the further you can
go and get an accurate reading the
better okay because if you think about
it taking an average over a large number
will give you a more accurate average
right it's like look I want the average
height of the class so I measure one
person and oh I'm really far from the
average if I pick badly I pick someone
like do you okay but if i measure five
people I'll get closer if I measure all
24 of you I'll get exactly right so how
far can we go and get an accurate read
for the straight line I reckon we can go
25 years yeah so here's the way that I
would set it out right um year zero
right ye 0 what is the salvage price
well as I actually establish price it's
the purchase price right and that's
fifteen thousand dollars okay um you
five what's the salvage price now what
do you read looks like about thousands
me too so now I'm going to refer that to
my formula she's not the only way to do
it by it's the most logical too much
logic way to do it I want to refer back
to my linear straight-line depreciation
formula alright so I've got a savage I
which is on 1000 write equals let's see
here the initial value minus okay daddy
that's what I'm trying to find that's
what I'm after like what is that amount
that I lost every year x 5 because
that's how many years
go see what I've got here let's simplify
a little bit kick this 5d over here so
it's not negative bring this 1000 over
ok so now i divide by 5 and what do you
get and you can see now how they've
gotten that you remember I told you the
answer says 12,200 here well that's
where they got it from 15,000 minus that
ok so this is a tricky thing is to get
more accurate readers now that is the
final question the exercise gives you
but I am going to ask a further question
which is it in this exercise but they'll
ask it later ok so I'm just going to rub
this off part if they said what's the
what's the straight-line depreciation
each year what do you think is the most
logical question to ask next good so if
this is the straight-line depreciation
let's work out the ducati balance
depreciation ok so this is f part 2 this
is the reason why I left those formulas
on the board ok just like I worked out
this value here by returning back to the
formula I'm gonna be the same thing but
for declining balance ok this is this
graph isn't it right so what does that
look like to you mmm
it's a bit about 3,000 isn't it I'm just
going to use three thousand because it's
a nice round number it's all approximate
anyway okay so this time you're going to
say three a thousand right that's how
much I've got after five years on
defining balance is equal to okay top me
up what should I put over here on the
right-hand side look at the formula
purchase price initial value which you
Tommy is 15,000 yep that's quite true I
suppose you'd call it videos 100 or 3200
I'm approximating so I'm just gonna I
think it's going to be open in an okay
margin of error they put you're quite
right ok now after that what happens
within the formula you got one minus and
ours what I'm trying to find that's
going to be the percentage I'm halftime
yeah to the power of five years good
let's tidy this up a little bit I've got
one over five here because that's what
3,000 / 15,000 years yeah equals one
minus R to the power of fire and what
I'm after is our so what would I do with
this thing now when you see something
like this if you see like x squared
equals nine right we're used to this you
take their what do you do to both sides
you take the square root so you get plus
or minus three I guess if this was an
amount of money we'd save just take the
positive if I showed you x squared
equals 100 and sorry x cubed equals 125
instead of taking the square root you
would take the cube root and then you
would get equals 5 okay so i'm good with
numbers surprised if i have raised this
to the power of 5 what would you expect
that i should do he are in order to
simplify square root cube root this
thing is going to be the fifth root
okay and you have a button for it on
your calculator so this is going to be 1
minus R on this side where you want to
look on your calculator is where you've
got your arm I think it's X to the power
of whatever okay and you can enter in
2345 what every night if you press shift
I think it's going to look like this
right yeah so I'm going to press that
button and then I want to put a 5 in
there so it gives me the fifth root of
whatever and if it was three years or
four years or ten years then you would
replace that that power in there ok
what's the 5th rate of 1 over 50 point
it is 0.7 0.72 for blah blah blah blah
oh k equals 1 minus R so now if i
rearrange this because i want our on its
own right i'll add art of this side and
I'll take aways 0.72 for on that side
right so we get R equals zero point two
seven six I think get someone check for
me I'm just doing about it yeah ok so
now this is a decimal right but we this
is um this is a percentage depreciation
okay so what would be a better way to
phrase it that would be twenty seven
point six percent and that's your amount
of depreciation
yeah so a question should specify and if
it doesn't that means that they will
accept a range of answers okay i think
twenty eight percent is probably okay
here because as was pointed out earlier
you know that three thousand dollars
that i started with that wasn't exactly
email so i'm always going to have a
little bit of a margin from up or down
and that's